[Music]
2020 was a challenging year for race
relations and issues of racial
inequality remain at the center of civil
discourse
unfortunately conversations involving
topics as diverse as community policing
workplace diversity training and the
teaching of american history
have radiated more heat than light lost
in these polarized debates is the
reality of unequal opportunity
in a first of its kind report i
co-authored with colleagues at aei and
brookings i studied the persistence of
poverty across three generations
from adults in the civil rights era to
their children and grandchildren
our findings reveal that while one in
five black americans in their thirties
are in their third generation of poverty
that's true of just one in one hundred
whites these disparities reflect greater
poverty among black americans 50 years
ago but also lower upward mobility
and greater downward mobility in
subsequent generations
remedying these inequalities should be a
priority for conservatives and liberals
alike
we must devote attention to alleviating
concentrated poverty early childhood
inequalities
and disparities in social capital while
also emphasizing the importance of
responsibility
for ourselves and for each other
what do you think is the best way to
increase upward mobility let us know in
our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei